.
Carla Oliveira.
- Le porte-parole du Parti
communiste chinois donne les
titititions aux journalistes
présents pour pouvoir couvrir
le congrès du Parti qui débute
dimanche. Un événement politique
qui revient tous les cinq ans.
(applaudissements)2300 déléguéss
par les assemblées du Parti
y seront présents.
Ils se retrouveront à huis clos,
pour renouveler les dirigeants
du pays. Mais, le suspense
est presque nul.
Xi Jinping, à l'aube de ses
70 ans, devrait se voir accorder
un troisième mandat comme
secrétaire général du parti et
comme présidena a a a République
populaire de Chine.
GUY SAINT-JACQUES, ancien
ambassadeur du Canada en Chine
- Ce qàààà l'encontre des
règles de succession qui avaient
été établies il y a à peu près
30 ans par Deng Xiaoping, à ce
moment-là c'était entendu qu'on
pouvait... comme un président,
un premier ministre pouvait
servir de mandat, donc
10 ans et quitter.
- Si on se fit aux congrès
antérieurs, il faudra attendre
au lendemain de la clôture
de l'événement pour l'annonce
officielle, incluant également
celle du comité permanent
du bureau politique, un groupe
restreint de sept à neuf hommes,
au sommet du pouvoir de l'État
chinois.
cicicici là, Xi Jinping fera le
bilan de son dernier quinquennat
et annoncera sa feuille de route
pour les cinq prochaines années.
En 2017,isisisiscours avait duré
plus de 3 h.
Le prochain gouvernement
chinois a quelques déjà
des défis devant lui.
La politique de zéro COVID,
imposée par Pékin et fortement
critiqué par l'OMS, ne pourra
pas continuer ainsi.
Les confinements draconiens
tirent l'économie du pays
vers le bas.
- Les experts disent que
l'économie, la croissance
va être réduite de 2 % à cause
de cette gestion-là. Ça a causé
aussi beaucoup de ressentiment
auprès de la population
chinoise. Il y a aussi beaucoup
de compagnies étrangères qui
commence à se dire : "Est-ce que
ça fait encore du sens de rester
en Chine?"
Et sur le dossier de Taiwan,
le Parti communisusususure que
le gouvernement exercera tous
ces pouvoirs pour ramener l'île
sous son giron.
Ici Carla Oliveira,
Radio-Canada, Montréa